everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie today I'm really excited because
we're gonna start what might end up
being the biggest project that we've
worked on so far since since I started
streaming I'm gonna may in May I think I
started streaming in May so today's
stream is going to be dedicated to
making some decisions before we actually
get started so may not actually be doing
some coding but this is an important
step that we haven't really gone over
before we've made some decisions in the
midst of coding but the things we talked
about today and end up deciding on will
really steer the direction that this
project goes so I just want to start out
by letting you all know what the end
goal is for the project and what are
some of the requirements that we're
going to need and then we can check out
our options I'll switch it up to the the
normal view with the really small you
know camera of me in the corner and then
I have a Trello board set up which
you'll eventually convert over to some
issues and github all right so so one
more thing by announcement there will be
two streams today this first stream is
going to be out this this project it'll
be on the free code camp channel I'm
going to stream again around 6:00 p.m.
Eastern time I'm going to give a guest
lecture I would be a guest lecturer in a
computer science course here at the
university that I teach at so I will be
talking about the work that I do here
that you all participate in in the
stream and also I'm going to give some
advice to how to search for jobs and
coding how to improve
your skills and I'm going to talk about
some of the latest technologies that
seem to be trending now and then I'm
going to take questions from the
students and from all of you so if
you're interested you have an
opportunity I know you know those of you
and in India it'll be the middle of the
night or early early morning so it might
be hard for you to make it but you can
make that stream I think that'll end up
being on my personal channel so check
the link in the description for that
channel I didn't know I was going to be
guest lecturing until this morning I
didn't really have time to check with
Quincy to see if he wanted something
like that on the free code camp channel
so I will probably be streaming it from
my phone in the classroom and I'm really
excited about this I think this will be
cool all right so let's get to this
project let me tell you first of all we
did talk a little bit about this project
a few weeks ago so for some of you this
you may remember a bit of this but I now
have a date when this project has to be
completed by which we didn't have before
and it's going to be somewhat of a tight
deadline not for us I know we can get
this done but in terms of all the other
decisions that have to be made by people
at the university higher up content
decisions and things like that it's
going to be tough so this site needs to
launch before March 6 2018 all right so
I'm thinking just try to get this site
completed in about three months and then
do some testing and get this launched
we're redoing completely from the ground
up I'm talking hosting servers all the
backend code new content management
system new databases certainly new
front-end everything is going to change
for this website and this is a site that
currently has over 3,000 pages of
content
on it it gets millions of views a year
so by far it's going to be our biggest
project yet then turn both in terms of
size of the website and the number of
view users that we need to be able to
support okay
now having said that the site itself is
not that complicated at least for now
there are no forms we don't have to
handle any form data there's not going
to be any user login so that takes out a
lot of complexity we're going to have
data coming in from multiple sources so
we're gonna have to handle that it's not
just going to be one content management
system it's more likely that we may pull
in data from different sources but we
should be able to handle that the site
has to be SEO friendly so it will didn't
need server-side rendering we're going
to be making API calls for all our
content search engines will not write or
wait around the display what comes in
through the API call so we definitely
want whatever we end up going with we're
gonna use react so that's already
decided we're definitely gonna use react
we have I I certainly have the most
experience with using react and so I'm
going with that but pretty much
everything else is up for debate alright
so here's what I'm thinking right now so
we have content management system will
be WordPress unless we can find a
content management system that's
suitable that's based on node I would
love to have JavaScript all the way
front-end back-end in the CMS everything
that's going to make it so much easier
to maintain and define people to hire to
work on this when we just need somebody
who knows JavaScript as opposed to
trying some find somebody that knows PHP
and JavaScript WordPress is PHP base
today so probably WordPress but I am
open
I just currently don't know of an open
source free node CMS that is at that
level of nothing is going to be at the
level of WordPress in terms of the
community that it has but in terms of
user friendliness for the people
entering data it has to at least come
close to WordPress to consider switching
so that that's going to take some
serious thought but we don't have to
worry about that right now we can
certainly begin developing this site
before we decide on the CMS so that's
something that can can hold off we could
test some things out let me switch over
now to my my list here in Trello so
sorry you won't be able to see my face
fullscreen anymore I know you might be
disappointed by that but that's
definitely a joke by the way I'm not I
don't really think that okay
oh we've got a lot of users right now I
just looked over at the analytics so
there may be some new people watching if
so welcome this is a little bit
different than what we normally do
normally we do a lot more coding today
is more planning but we'll get into some
coding you know in future videos
probably the next one we do will
actually start setting this project up
let me you know what I'm gonna have to
remember to periodically look over at
the live chat I haven't been doing a
great job so let me give it a little
look here but you while I'm looking at
that if you can see the screen you can
see some of let me go down to some of
our questions there we go
so let me read off of a few of these
questions we need to talk about I'll
give you a minute to kind of think about
it while I catch up on what you are
saying in the live chat so we need to
decide on a UI framework so I'm talking
about are we gonna use material UI are
we gonna use some other framework I
already know what harsh it's gonna say
he's gonna say no way from its hero UI
but I'm open to suggestions their only
thing is it
to be material design friendly what are
we going to use for testing I'd love to
have this thing 100% fully covered with
with testing so I'm gonna need help with
that one because if you all watch before
you know I'm not really great with with
testing so I'll rely on your advice for
that and then whatever we choose I'll
learn it and we'll do it should we use
redux may not be able to make this
decision right away because we'll have
to see where the data is coming from how
complex it is so we may hold off on that
a little bit we can certainly develop a
lot and then add in Redux afterwards so
in terms of the UI we could probably
build that all out without having to
worry about Redux what CMS should we use
we've talked about that and where am I
going to host this are we going to use
digital ocean we're gonna use AWS what
what are we going to do and here's the
thing right now there's certainly a ton
of URLs that are being linked to from
elsewhere do we want to keep the URLs
I'm thinking yes it would I would hate
to have all those links break but then
if we are going to keep them how what's
the best way to do this how do we set up
our routing structure to be able to best
match up our site with the old URLs I
don't know that we'll be able to keep
all of them things are going to change
but if we can avoid breaking a lot of of
inbound links from elsewhere then I'd
love to do that I do have a phone call
coming in
I think I'm just gonna let it go to to
voicemail and because this isn't going
to be a really long stream I do have a
meeting to go to in about an hour so all
right so think about all those for a
minute and I'm gonna see what you all
have already said about these in the
live chat
okay so harsh it's recommending we
should use Gatsby
so if you're not familiar with Gatsby
gassi Gatsby is comparable to in the
same class as create react app next j/s
it's like a way to scaffold your react
app pay and they all come with with pros
and cons so we'll have to consider
Gatsby I have not used Gatsby personally
I've used next I've used create react
app haven't used Gatsby yet so I'll
consider it but I mean I'm tending to
lean more towards things that I'm more
familiar with but if there's something
that's clearly better I'm open to
learning it but given our time frame -
we have to be reasonable about that see
hey everybody a lot of people are saying
hi hey welcome let's see
okay hearts just recommending use draw
dot IO for planning actually it's not a
bad idea I think I may do that I'm
probably gonna do it right now but I'll
check that out after the stream yeah and
there's definitely a Harsha says yay
more PR opportunities there's going to
be so many opportunities for you all to
contribute both in the planning stages
and an actual pull request so I I don't
expect anyone to contribute I'm not
asking for contributions I realize your
time is very valuable but I definitely
welcome contributions and I appreciate
them very much so if any of you would
like to build up your your github
profile a bit and would like to
contribute to this project
I really really appreciate that and
there's going to be plenty of work to do
okay
okay we got a recommendation to use
react materialized for the UI all right
I'll check it out I've checked it out a
while ago and it wasn't really up to
what I needed at the time but I'm
welcome to check it out again I think we
had bootstrap semantic UI okay we can
check those out we just need to star in
some way to easily use material design
styles with those so I'm open to going
with something that's not material
design related by default if there's
some easy way to kind of add that on
okay harsh it says if we use Gatsby we
don't need to use Redux okay let's see
we have Booma which is another UI
framework let's see
ok so we have some suggestions for
hosting so we have a suggestion of AWS
because of the traffic that we're
getting this site that may be the best
let's see all right I got a lot of stuff
coming in so how about let's let's do
this let's start right again some of
these suggestions here so let me zoom
out a bit on this this is Trello by the
way if you're not familiar with Trello
it's it's kind of nice to be able in
this case I'm using it like a Kanban
board but it's nice to help plan out the
project so let's go with the the hosting
so let's just throw in AWS as an option
there and UI framework we got a lot of
options so I'll zoom in as well he or
she all can see let's make this a
checklist how about that and then we can
check things off once we rule them out
that seems like it'll be the easiest
all right so material uy we had a
bootstrap and I'm going to shorten these
like obviously I'm not gonna use plain
old bootstrap right I'm gonna use the
react version of bootstrap so somebody
some repo that's taking bootstrap and
turn it into react components right same
way it's like materialized right basic
materialized is not for react but there
is a version for react boom ah lose the
other one I kept saying semantics
semantics okay I think I got I think
that's everything I saw let's see
actually you know what I want to do is
well since we I didn't have this up here
as something to check out but let's see
let me just call this should call
framework for lack of a better term I'm
gonna call this framework for now just
so that we can have a list to go by go
through some pros and cons and let's go
with create react app next J s and
Gatsby
so you spelled Gatsby I think so but it
just looks weird to me for some reason
yeah that's how you fill gas fee okay
let me scroll through just a bit see if
I missed anything
okay here's another another good thing
that we haven't talked about yet but we
should think about database so it
depends really on what CMS we're using
because if it's wordpress usually you
typically use my sequel with WordPress
but if we end up one with some other
content management system potentially we
could we don't even have to use anything
that's sequel based we could use MongoDB
we need use whatever we wanted you know
we could go with couch for anything
really so I'm not sure but that question
is going to be tied into the CMS so the
answer is basically we're gonna go with
whatever database is best suited to the
content management system that we choose
so I think we can put that question off
until we decide for sure on a content
management system okay so it looks like
gatsby has this very similar routing
system to next j/s which is good because
i'm familiar with that I definitely need
to be able to use
I think react router on top of it to do
some custom stuff I can see that being
somewhat necessary later on down the
road which I think that shouldn't be a
problem
Gatsby has graph QL already built in
which is wonderful because I do want to
use graph QL we're going to talk more
about that in a minute as well so keep
that my if anybody's familiar with graph
QL please stick around because we have
somewhat of a dilemma with where our
data is house right now we got to fix
that before any of this can really
happen in terms of populating what we
build with with content
all right okay
rob is asking what's the best place to
go and find out about getting set up to
do pool requests I've never used react I
guess let me know you can you can ask
questions here in the live chat or you
can send me a message on Twitter or
whatever first I want to know what what
is your experience with with github and
pull requests in general have you done
that before and just never done it with
react or have you never done a pool
request before with github at all
that'll once I know that I think I'll be
able to help you out more I just kind of
want to know where we're with our where
we're starting at but I definitely
welcome pool requests from from anyone
even if you're not familiar at all with
it I'll try to help you out if it needs
changes I'll try to suggest changes to
you and really help you to be able to
make a good pull request
all right so definitely welcome I very
rarely turn down a pull request always
try to grab you know get something
useful out of each pull request and
merge it in so if you're looking to get
your first pull request merged this is a
great place to do it not only in this
project but any of the other projects
that we've done in live coding with
Jesse so keep that in mind if you're new
and want to get something on your github
profile
alright Michael Lee says Jesse you are
the best we love you I love you all too
thanks for saying that I really do I
look forward to this dream every day
I really love it ok so a Mon is saying
[ __ ] will be good honestly I really I I
would like to work with [ __ ] I've never
worked with longer before I think would
be cool it just kind of depends on what
ends up being the best to use with our
CMS oh ok
also another plus for Gatsby it has
plug-ins for WordPress so we can grab
the data and pull it into that bat graph
QL that's built in which means we don't
have to use WP graph QL the plugin which
we're using on another project that
we're working on so I actually have had
no problems with the WP graph QL plugin
plugin I really like it we had the the
creator of that plugin and on the on the
live streams before so I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with it but if we
have something built in that's also cool
lanique s can you explain this project I
can I don't know if you join late so I
did explain it earlier so I'm just going
to give very very brief overview for all
of you they're joining because I can see
there's a lot of viewers that have just
joined recently let me give a one-minute
explanation just to catch everybody up
if you want to know more after the
stream is over go back and watch the
first like ten minutes so basically
we're gonna build a react site it's
going to grab data from different data
sources content management systems and
things it's going to pull it in and it's
going to display it on a page it needs
to be server-side rendered for search
engine optimization purposes but really
it's it's simple it just needs to be
able to handle a lot of traffic and
needs to be able to display data in a
very user-friendly way obviously we're
gonna go with you know progressive web
app style right I think if you admit
building anything new why not make it a
progressive web app but other than that
it's not going to be that much different
than your typical blog like a react blog
it's just going to be huge there's going
to be a lot more just in terms of
different types of pages and different
types of content that are going to need
to be displayed so but the basic
principles of pulling in data and just
displaying it are the same no login we
don't have to handle user data we don't
have to handle form data as far as I
know
now of course project requirements
change I'm sure you all have had
projects before where the requirements
have changed at some point that
certainly can happen but as of right now
this is what the project needs alright
Postgres all right I've never used that
before as well but I'm certainly open to
you if for those you don't know that's
another type of database let's see
okay so if you remember Rob asked a
little while ago about pool requests Rob
says I've done pool requests several
times I would say a little of a beginner
okay great so you're already familiar
with the pool request it's going to be
the same process and to be honest with
you even if you don't know anything
about react there's gonna be other
things that need done and I'm not just
talking about the typical like fixed
typos and a readme file they're gonna be
CSS things that need done
so if you know something about CSS but
not particularly about react hey you can
take a shot at that there's gonna be
probably what else we'll need we're
gonna have some node going on right so
we're gonna write some things so if you
understand node even if you don't
understand react you'll still be able to
contribute in that way so there's going
to be opportunities sometime within the
next week I'm going to create a repo for
this and I'm gonna put a ton of issues
in there and then you all be able to see
broken down into small chunks what needs
done and if you feel like it's something
you'd really like to do then take a shot
at it and I'm happy to help if you do
need any help all right I'm almost
nearly through a lot of the discussion
now so let me get through this last
little bit and then we'll see where
we're at in terms of our questions make
sure we haven't missed anything and
started getting to some of the other
some of the other things we have to
decide on oh okay a Dylan asks about a
CMS it's a content management system so
if you're familiar with let's say
WordPress Drupal Joomla those are really
popular PHP based ones it's just a user
interface where someone is not really
familiar with coding at all can input
data and then that data can be not just
data but usually like media images and
things like that
can input that and then that can be used
in a website all right Jesse McIntyre
says yeah this stream is incredible so
helpful to see how a real pro approaches
the project yeah I mentioned this before
but I am a professional web front-end
developer in terms of that if you take
the word professional to mean I get paid
to do this if the word pro means I'm
like really really good at my job I
don't claim that all right I'm I'm just
trying to do the best work that I can
and learn more every day so if if I can
help somebody out and learn from that
wonderful but more often than not I
learned from you all so I guess just
keep that in mind I will make mistakes
it will definitely happen but hopefully
we can all learn something from those
mistakes and then end up building
something awesome okay
world's ass are we going to use react
native not right away I'd really love to
do some react native projects that will
take some of the things that we're
working on now and just regular react
and then convert them to react native if
you're not familiar with react native
it's really awesome I did a video about
it maybe a few weeks ago so I think if
you search react native within the free
code camp set of videos you'll find it I
believe it's the only react native video
we have right now but anyway react
native is a way for you to use react
right JavaScript and then have that be
converted into native code that runs on
an Android device or an iOS device so
it's really awesome so it's if you were
familiar with ionic or PhoneGap a little
bit older technology it was a way to use
JavaScript and make apps but it didn't
it's not exactly the same this goes a
step further and what actually gets on
the device is
the action so I believe in Android it's
Java although I don't know people are
using Kotlin now so I'm not sure exactly
what it gets converted to and then iOS
is Swift I believe so the device doesn't
read the joy it's not doing JavaScript
but you get to use javascript which is
wonderful built my first react native
app about a month ago really cool
process so I'd love to be able to do
that on a stream but so maybe after this
project we'll get into that Michael says
I don't understand half of what's going
on and I'm still excited awesome I'm
really excited as well so I think this
would be a really cool project ok cool
so it looks like hard [ __ ] and the live
chat is super excited to use Gatsby so
I'm definitely going to have to do my
research on Gatsby after the stream
today and in tomorrow morning and and
check that out so if anybody else has
used Gatsby before please let me know
what you think about it in the live chat
or you can send me a message on Twitter
anywhere you can find me on the internet
any social media platform feel free to
message me on there whatever you like
the best you can email me if you can
find my phone number and you can call me
it's out there okay good there's a good
question so what is the difference
between client-side react and
server-side I've never done the
server-side this is a great question
so server-side react I'll just taking I
think the best way to explain it would
be an example so with the server-side
react your client so that the browser
users browser it gets basically an HTML
page already completely compiled right
so the server on the server all API
calls will be made all the
we'll be there it'll all get rendered
HTML and then sent at least on the first
load after that potentially you could
switch over to some client-side routing
just for Speed purposes do prefetching
which will probably do but the cool
thing about that is that search engines
can see that now let's flip it around
and only use client-side if we only use
client-side routing what the browser
gets is not the full HTML it's just the
skeleton that needs to be filled with
the data but instead what happens is the
clients browser gets all the code then
the JavaScript fires makes your calls to
your API pools and the data and then
renders for a typical user that'll
happen so fast it's not really that much
of a difference but for a web crawler
right leg oogle scroll or Bing or
whatever they don't stick around long
enough for that API data to come back so
all they're gonna see on the page is
just potentially nothing or just the
bare minimum that you already had kind
of hard-coded in there so it's gonna see
it's never gonna see the data that you
want it to see for search engine
optimization so yeah and I just see
harsh it says Google now renders
JavaScript yeah it renders JavaScript
that's true but it doesn't stick around
on the page long enough to render API
calls so if all our data is coming from
elsewhere through API is it will not
render this so I did a lot of testing
with this on some some sites that I
built a few months ago and it is true
you can get it to render JavaScript but
not API data so I'll keep that in mind
if you're using react or any type of
single page application if you're if the
project needs search engine optimization
you gotta have compensate for that and
server-side routing is typically the way
that that that is done
I'm sorry server-side rendering I'm
sorry I misspoke okay
let's see ok so Ali says sounds like a
long-term project how about using
reactive reason would be a great
learning experience I've seen a lot of
people on Twitter talk about react the
reason I'm not very familiar with it at
all so like I said I'm very open to new
things as long as if I'm gonna switch
from something I know to something new
it has to be clearly a better option
because that's that's going to set us
back because I'll have to learn it so
given our time frame which I'm gonna say
we're only going to spend about 3 months
what's beginning in November December
January yeah I want this done by
February and then I want to suspend a
whole month testing so it's ready to go
by the end of February in February a
short month so we get we gotta get it
going so anyway so let's keep that in
mind when we're choosing what to use is
that we there's definitely going to be a
trade-off and in some cases if the
difference between what we know already
and the new thing that might be better
if it's a small difference then we're
gonna stick with what we know just so
that we can get things done faster okay
I think that's that's a reasonable
that's kind of a reasonable plan right
let me know if you disagree but if we
had lots more time then I would think
differently about it but this is a
shorter deadline than I expected to have
just found out about this yesterday
after you know I just found out about
that this morning actually so yeah so
about 9:30 a.m. this I I got an email
found out about this date so just to
explain the reason for the date our
contract I don't think I explained this
but the contract for our current system
is up on this March the 6:20
18 so we have to pay more money for next
year's contract if we still have it but
if we can get this done then we'll save
a lot of money from the our contracts
because the current content management
system is there's a yearly fee for it so
there's definitely a decent a good
financial incentive to get this done
sooner okay so we have a question what
are the steps to contribute to this
project you know what
we're gonna have a structured
contribution file in the github repo so
they'll be very clear steps with the
tape or what to do when you want to
contribute so just hold on for that I'll
have that ready whenever I make the repo
but basically I'm gonna have a bunch of
issues ready you can pick out the issue
and try to solve it submit a pull
request and potentially if everything is
good then we'll merge it or if you come
up with a feature or something that you
think would be really cool and on your
own initiatives you want to contribute
then I'm good with that potentially you
might have a less of a chance to get
merged depending on on whether or not I
I think the features needed or not or we
should use it so you may want to run it
by me first but I'm open there's been a
lot of times when somebody has submitted
a pull request for a feature that I
never even thought of and it's awesome
and I'm more than happy to pull it into
the project so I don't have a super
complicated process for submitting pool
requests so I like to keep it pretty
basic so that those of you who are newer
at the process have kind of a low
barrier to entry and can get those full
request sent but are more details for
you and we actually get the repo started
which which should be maybe tomorrow
okay here's another question is it
better to use Redux with react for large
scalable projects and what is the best
folder structure architecture eirick in
general I recommend using Redux for
larger projects it really helps keep
your data flow reasonable right it's
very easy to deal with data on a small
project you can just use state it's you
know component state it's fine once it
starts to get bigger it's really hard to
pass state and props down through lots
of components and it can be a mess Redux
helps you simplify all that so I would
say in general yes the larger more
complex projects will benefit from Redux
but it does depend on your your project
so just because you have a big project
doesn't necessarily mean you have to use
Redux but I've found Redux to be very
helpful
okay this show asks what's the best way
to make API calls besides fetch I don't
know if there's a better way than fetch
right now okay I like to use fetch now I
know people like to use what is it Axios
I haven't used Axios but I maybe it's
better here's my thought on it if X is
already usable and at least depending on
like client-side depending on the
browser it's already there right why add
in something else if it doesn't add in
more functionality than fetch dos like
keep things light right maybe
Axios does something that fetch can't do
but I'm unaware of that so I don't
really think I could give you a great
answer for that because I pretty much
stick with fetch I mean you know before
fetch of course you know we use Ajax
right
but yeah I've I'm pretty happy with
fetch
okay so hacky you see says what about
using react static instead of Gatsby
okay I am not familiar with react static
but I'll add it to our list
and I'll have to look that up
let's see Pedro says Elm I'm not
familiar with Elm if there's if there's
good reasons we could use that let me
know in infamous sorry I'm having listen
up on the name here but anyway it says
how will you be notified will it be
through here or a sign-up sheet I think
the best way to notify is if you want to
get notified whenever I'm going to go
live with videos then subscribe to free
code camps Channel and make sure you
have notifications on for that channel
on YouTube I also tweet about what I'm
doing and when I'm gonna post or do a
new live stream so if you'd like to you
can follow me on twitter and then you
know you you'll be able to see my tweets
about what i'm going to do things and
then finally whenever I get the github
repo up and running which will likely be
tomorrow or the next day you can star
that repository and then you'll know
where to go you can get I guess there's
other ways you could do it potentially
you can follow me on github I guess and
then my activity will show up so there's
several different ways you can keep
track of the project so those those
three ways are probably the most
reliable ways to stay up to date on
what's going on and of course is what
about sagas yeah so I'm not Redux sagas
is another way to handle the handle data
flow handle state and react I have not
used sagas so far I've I basically used
thunks it's a redux funk so I'm open to
using saw
if we find that that's that would be
better but once again that would be
something I'll have to learn so if you
all think that would be a better thing
to do just you know let me know okay
harsh it says Axios has better api than
fetch okay
Axios then may be easier to use so like
I said I've never really had a problem
with the fetch API it seems pretty
straight straightforward to me but I
haven't actually used axia so I I can't
give a good you know opinion on one
versus the other
okay okay worlds as on the previous
projects one through four which do you
recommend to get up to speed so if you
haven't watched the stream before this
is the fifth project that we're working
on now we've done four projects before
this and I believe they were all react
projects right does it all react maybe
we might have done one that wasn't react
but anyway we've done at least three
react projects before this so if you
want to get up to speed I would say
project three will have kind of the
latest stuff with project three we're
using react 16 we're using the latest
version of material UI so that would be
helpful but if you want to learn more
about server-side rendering then check
out project 1 we use next J s for
server-side rendering just a disclaimer
we did those projects earlier you know
months ago so a lot of the things we use
to have newer versions now so it may not
match up exactly with the latest
versions so I mean but obviously we
can't do anything about that right we we
use the latest versions that were
available at the time so I just want to
warn you all so you just realize that
you may want to check up on the latest
Doc's and see if anything has changed
but you know it's only been a few months
so it shouldn't be too drastic things
should all you know still work but that
would be my recommendation 1 or 3 for
the projects if you have time you know
check out
wait I'm sorry I'm sorry for is where we
use react 16 project for we use your X
16 so my mistake
so check out project 1 if you want to
look at some how we did server-side
rendering and check out project 4 if you
want to see the latest version of react
and the latest version of material UI ok
yeah ok another question is it fine to
create subfolders for different modules
and actions reducers containers
components yeah it's certainly fine
structure folder structure is there are
recommended ways to do it but you
there's certainly room for adjustment
based on your particular situation of
what works best for you for your team so
I think it's ok it's good to use
somewhat of a standard structure
especially if it's going to be on github
and an open source you want people to be
able to understand what's going on but
with in somewhat of a standard structure
if you need to make you know some
adjustments depending on what works best
for you then as long as it's not too
drastic I don't see a problem with that
at all ok can you post your github first
movies ok the github I believe I have a
link to my github profile in the
description but if I don't I'll post it
so I don't have this particular
repository up yet but I will have it up
soon and I'll have the link for you
ready in the next live stream which
should be tomorrow so also I'll give it
to you let's see alright so you have a
few people joining in a little bit later
so in is here hey how's it going thanks
for joining us Albert's is asking for
update about the project just real basic
it's going to be react and we're going
to grab data from
content management system and pull it in
with graph QL we're gonna pull that data
in we're going to render it on the
server side and we're gonna create a
react app a progressive web app that is
going to basically just display data not
going to be a ton of interactivity going
on but we need it to be able to handle a
pretty significant load so that's the
project now if you want more details go
back after this stream and watch the
first 10 minutes of it and I go into in
more details about it projects ok
another question what is better way to
write reducers switch in cases or
something like actually saying when I
write reducers I usually use a switch
statement there may be a better way but
I found switch statements to be really
straightforward easy to read easy to
write so I would stick with that okay we
got a question about the start date for
this project I'm saying today's the
start date right this is the day we
start the planning the actual coding
might start tomorrow if we can if I can
get some enough information to make a
good decision about some things then we
might start coding tomorrow in terms of
design we already actually have quite a
bit of the design finish from previous
projects previous work we've done so
that's not going to be too much of an
issue I mean I know people might refer
you coffee and doughnuts while watching
Joe Hanson says are you gonna be handing
out coupon codes for free coffee and
donuts while watching this new project I
do not have any coupon codes for free
coffee and donuts sorry about that I can
put little Coffee emojis in the live
chat every once in a while if you want
that's that's probably as good as it can
it can get I apologize if I could I'd
send you all free coffee and donuts but
haha novice who right now okay so we
have a question about links to previous
project repos okay so here's the best
thing to catch up on new projects within
free code can YouTube channel which is
what we're on right now just check out
the live coding with Jesse playlist and
you can see the different projects I
usually have in parentheses at the end
of the title it'll say like P 1 D 2 so V
project 1 day 2 so if you click in the
any of those videos in the description
it will have all the links you need to
catch up on the project so the github
repo will be there for sure and then
potentially a link to a Trello board or
other things that were using for that
particular project I'm in the process of
creating separate playlists for each
project project for now as its own
separate playlist and I'm going to get
the other projects into their own
playlist soon so it'll be a little bit
easier the live coding with Jessie
playlist what has everything all in one
playlist so if you want to see
everything that's the one but it's it's
a lot there's over a hundred videos in
there now so we're separating them out
into separate playlists make it easier
for you ok let's see all right so let me
I'm gonna stop with the live chat just
for a minute to make sure that we've
gone over these questions and then we'll
wrap this up for a little while and I'll
do a little bit of research and if you
all want to keep giving me suggestions
that's fine we do have a getter channel
the links in the description if you want
to join in on there
and talk about it in the getter channel
we have a slack channel if you want to
send me your email address I can invite
you to that Channel and then of course
I'm available
on all the social media things alright
so host okay here is a very important
thing that we need to get up and running
and I need your advice for this won't
this may not be something that we can
have on github although potentially we
could but right now we have all the data
for the current website in a sequel
database what we're gonna do is copy
that database and then try to build an
API so that we can easily pull that data
out put it into another database in the
format necessary for whatever content
management system that we have so what I
need then is your opinion on what's the
best way to go about doing something
like that in terms of creating the API
has anyone has experience with things
like that before is the idea just silly
am i is this is wishful thinking that we
can do this so let me know and then
potentially if anybody is really
experienced a building api's like that
pulling data let me know and maybe we
can talk more about it so I don't
currently have access to the database
I'm working with another department here
at the University I work for because
they have access to that database so I'm
gonna get the access soon hopefully
and and then we can start working on
that but otherwise this is going to be
really hard to get the data in because
that would then require manually copying
and pasting things I don't want to do
that I do not want to do that at all it
wouldn't be me we'd probably hire
student workers to do it but that's in
my opinion that's not really an option
there's got to be a better way to do it
so that's the way I'm thinking right now
but I'm definitely open to suggestions
all right that was I think the last
major thing that we needed to think of
so we've gone over all the questions
haven't necessarily gone through all the
potential answers to them but I just
wanted you all to be able to
know what's going on with the project
right off the bat and just kind of get
everybody thinking so let me go back to
the live chat probably just a few more
minutes for the stream and then I'm
gonna have to get ready for my next for
my next meeting and and then like I said
there will be another live stream later
on today I'm going to be a guest
lecturer in a computer science course
and I'm going to talk about some advice
for new coders and some of the latest
trends in front-end development that'll
be at 6 p.m. Eastern Time and it'll be
on my youtube channel links in the
description okay I got a couple more
questions ok so Austin wants to make an
API call every 30 minutes do you have a
good way of implementing that I don't
know off the top of my head I don't know
how it implement that for sure if you
have a github repo where you try to have
this code please share the link with me
you don't have to share it in the live
chat you can send me a direct message on
Twitter or something like that I'll be
happy to check it out for you and give
you some advice but I would kind of want
to see what you're working with right
now before I could give you a good
answer on that can you see okay another
question I'm thinking of going to
hackathon this weekend what can I begin
or such intermediate front-end dev do in
a hackathon actually I'm gonna make a
confession right now I've never been to
a hackathon so um I'm not entirely sure
but I would imagine that you need a
front-end dev right if there's gonna be
any type of UI for whatever you're
creating at a hackathon you need it you
need somebody to make it right so
certainly you could you could do that
and I mean I'm sure there's gonna be
other things as well
I mean I'm I'm front-end dev but I do
some back-end stuff when necessary I do
some DevOps stuff when I need to I set
up
servers like so you know potentially
you've probably done some of that too
and when you have to a project so and
you bring another perspective so at the
very least your opinion will probably be
valuable now like I said I've not been
to a hackathon if somebody else has more
experience with hackathons then maybe
you could offer some good advice but I'd
say I definitely think you'd have
something to contribute
okay this all says how would you
normally architect your project or plan
before actually starting so that you
don't hit a dead end later okay normally
a lot of my planning is somewhat like
like this it's just it starts out with
really broad categories and then
eventually this list will change and it
will start to get really small tiny
tasks okay and I estimate how long each
task will take and then I have a decent
estimate and I can then allocate a
certain number of hours per week and
figure out what is actually reasonable
in the deadline and what features have
to be pushed and be added in later so
that's roughly how I do that I'm usually
very good about meeting deadlines there
are some factors you just can't you just
can't know beforehand so scope creep
like project requirements all of a
sudden changing and it's it's more
difficult or you know things just going
wrong right
you have illness people who you need to
get stuff from to continue the project
aren't getting it to you on time so I
usually build in some padding some time
there beyond what I think it will take
just to account for those those unknown
things but that's how I generally do
projects especially if it's just kind of
me that's the one doing most of the
development if I had more of a team that
worked right here with me
I would probably have a different
process there would be a lot more
scheduling around other people and what
they're doing to so it'd be a little bit
more complex but anyway this is how I do
it I'm sure there's probably better ways
to do it and I'd love to learn about him
if you all have some advice on that but
but this is kind of my my workflow as it
is right now
okay harsh it says which content
management system and database is the
site using now great question the
content management the site's using now
is Frank it's a X Ron so the website is
Franciscan dot edu the content
management system is called Ektron it
runs off of like dotnet framework it's
on a Windows Server the database I
believe some some type of sequel
database to tell you the truth I don't
know I don't even know for sure what
kind of database it is but that's it
it's it's in bad shape the the content
management system is lacking some
features that people have come to expect
from content management systems and it's
it's very tedious to update even simple
things so we've been wanting to get get
move it to something a little bit nicer
for awhile now
okay so why not it says why not use
firebase firestore for database Hey
in terms of our plan for restoring data
and database of stuff I'm open to things
as long as it fits all the requirements
then I'm fine with checking out
different things whatever is the best
that we can use that we can reasonably
use for the project I'm fine with that
to be honest I have not worked directly
with firebase so I'm not really in a
position to make a decision on that
right now I'd have to do some more
research
okay Michael asks if I can link to this
this board this Trello board yes I can
I'll try to make this board public and
include a link in the video description
I'll try to have that ready for for
tomorrow and then probably way I'll do
it is I'll just make it viewable from
the public otherwise it'll be crazy if
everybody can edit this but I'll
certainly make this viewable and what
I'm going to do all as well as once we
get some really concrete to do's I'm
going to convert those two issues in the
github repo so then we can have
discussion within that issue as well
okay all right here's another idea for
the database we should take sequel gum
and poured it to our new database make
tables according to to WordPress move
the data and then okay yeah I'm like I
said I'm open I'm not familiar enough
with databases my my experience with
databases is I've done some copying and
transferring of databases in the contact
context of moving WordPress sites to
different servers so that I'm very
limited in that so I'm I'm open and I'm
welcoming advice from those who you have
more experience with databases so and
that's something that I definitely like
to get done sooner rather than later
because it's an important piece to this
so yeah so just let me know what your
ideas are I have some people here on
campus that are database administrators
that I can talk to as well so I'm gonna
get their input on that and see if maybe
they have a better idea as well I
haven't had a chance to talk to anybody
about that yet this is all pretty I knew
this was coming for a while but I just
didn't know for sure when the project
was gonna start and when the due date
was so is this all happened suddenly
let's see okay we do join this board
yeah definitely I'm gonna make the board
public soon and then I'll have the link
in the description the video
descriptions for these live chats and
then you'll be able to check it out
whenever you want this show says I'm
moving from angular to react on a new
project I found angular more easy to get
on or maybe it's too early to judge but
I'm liking react to I am liking react to
many stuffs to learn yeah it's
definitely a switch but if you if you
were able to work with angular and learn
angular I certainly think that that you
have the ability to learn react as well
it's just a little bit different way of
thinking about things so
I think it will be a little bit harder
at first but if you like it and you're
committed to learning it then no doubt
no doubt you can you can learn it okay
michael says thanks I'm just starting
and I really don't know what steps to
take for example set up dev environment
oh yeah for this one where I say set up
dev environment if you're not familiar
with that the development environment in
terms of basically all the things that I
have running on my local machine what
I'm gonna do this so that to me at least
this encompasses everything from my code
editing code editor my linter
transpilers my web pack build which may
be taken care of depending on what we go
with for our framework right whether
next or Gatsby or create write that so
kind of all that is like my development
environment okay so a lot of that is
already kind of built up and it stays
the same for each project but I do like
to update in between projects to use
better tools or new tools so that's what
I mean by dev environment and we'll
basically I mean most this stuff on the
list will work through together well
it'll all be streamed it'll all be live
stream and work through it together so
if you'd like to learn more about any of
these things just you know stick around
and eventually we're gonna get to all of
it
okay okay so so harsh it's saying that
he doesn't think that we'll need to
build an API to get the data out he's
thinking we should we could just dump
the data since we're making a clone of
the original database there's no chance
of us harming it
all right I'll mention that when I when
I talk to the database guys here soon
I'll mention that as well as an option
and I'll see what they think
that might actually be they might be
more comfortable with that to be honest
with you see this shows us how does
Redux observable help in development I
have not had experience with using that
so I can't I have no advice to give you
there another answer there let's see a
question about the slack Channel
if you want to join the slack Channel I
need your email address and so don't
don't put in the live chat send it to me
on Twitter or something in a direct
message and then I can have an invite
sent to your email so you can't just go
to a link and have it work there is a
Gitter channel and you can use the link
and it can work it is LinkedIn oh you
know what I didn't put it in the
description
I forgot I meant to I'm gonna put it
here in the live chat so if anybody's
interested in joining our Gator channel
click the link that I just put into the
live chat and then you can join our git
er channel and I'll try to get that in
the video description if I don't forget
about it and so that way if if you can't
get the live shot now or if you're
watching this recording later on you'll
still have access to that
okay
okay so we have answer in terms of the
Redux observables so Harshit sang
observables are good for handling data
streams and then we had a question about
Redux thunk-thunk ER for async calls
yeah so you use thunk when you need to
make some async calls like API calls
things like that so I mean that's like
just really basic what they do but
anyway thunks were really helpful for me
and really simple to learn so if you
need to make some calls
Aysen calls with redux I would check out
func first before moving on to something
else like sagas it seems to me that
thunk is like really basic and easy to
figure out okay
I've gone through everything in the live
chat at this point if I missed your
question or comment I apologize I tried
to get to everything feel free to
comment on this video if I missed it or
ask me or comment on any other social
media or just come back for another
stream and and and ask me about it
so I'm gonna end the stream in just a
minute thank you so much everyone for
joining us in the live stream we had
quite a few viewers in here so our
that's awesome I really appreciate it a
lot of activity and the lives had a lot
of great suggestions so it's just super
helpful for me thank you so much and you
know please join us back for you know I
I really want to collaborate and have
this project be like our project and all
of us contribute ideas and and code and
everything and just work through this
whole thing start to finish I think that
would be really cool if you can watch
later on don't forget I'm live-streaming
my guest lecture and computer science
course you'll learn a little bit about
front-end development about some advice
for new code coders trying to find jobs
and things and get experience it will be
at 6 p.m. Eastern Time and that will be
on my youtube channel so
not the free code camp channel you can
find the description to my channel in
the or the link to my channel in the
description for this video I'll probably
put out a tweet before I do that so that
you all can link to get a link directly
to the video and I've never done a live
stream from my phone so I'm gonna try
that out later hopefully it goes well
but the students are going to be able to
ask me questions but you all will be
able to ask me questions as well on the
live chat so you know if you have any
questions feel free and I'd love to see
you all there if you can if you're at a
time zone where it'll be a weird time I
totally understand so don't worry about
it
get some sleep okay alright get through
everything just double-check you don't
want to miss any anything all right so
I'll be back a little later on today and
then I'll be back again just going
continuing with this project tomorrow
somewhere around 2 p.m. Eastern time
I'll let you all know on Twitter and
there'll be a notification if you
subscribe to the free code camp Channel
until then have a wonderful day
and and I'll see y'all tomorrow or later
maybe